we've scoured the city for the hottest
new fitness disciplines these are the
workouts everyone's talking about
we've got turf set white eyed tabata
yoga and boot camp it's your body
this is fighting to me I am will and
this is Tabata
this is your at-home tabata leg workout
hey guys we're here with will we're
gonna do a legs to bottom workouts
friends don't let friends skip leg day
so we're not gonna like to skip that leg
day today we're gonna focus on two
movements that will focus on our quads
and also our posterior chain which is
basically all the muscles that run up
the back of your body the first move is
the air squat when you set up for your
squat you want to set up basically under
your shoulders from here you gonna send
your hips back and you're gonna squat
down till your hips are below your knee
doing this is gonna help you engage calf
and lower back upper back you're
engaging everything when you do it in a
Tabata style the speed is down up so
you're really popping your hips open at
the top and pulling yourself back down
the second is the walking lunge this is
gonna engage your quad and a little more
hip flexor lunge down me down and up
then you're gonna alternate back and
forth so 20 seconds of air squats 10
seconds of rest 20 seconds of walking
lunges 10 seconds rest ok 4 rounds let's
do this guy's
3 2 1 go that's it there you go it's
tougher than it looks and rest
deep breath in and go
and three two one breaths see I like
this part the rest part that's a party
right yeah yeah now we're gonna try to
get the same amount of reps that we did
in the first one another faster come on
bill not slightly slightly less good a
little bit on your balance soon five
seconds
cool see the 10 second rest for the full
tabata you double that for four you'll
be done so to recap we start off with 20
seconds of air squats 10 seconds of rest
20 seconds of walking lunges followed by
10 seconds to rest repeat that process
for times that gives you a complete -
bot our legs workout thanks a lot man
appreciate it thank you
make sure to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any other fighting weight
episodes